in the morning I'll take the shake just
before it's time to eat my breakfast and
it brings my blood sugar down it
sometimes it comes down to about 99 and
then I could eat my breakfast and take
it back up some but not over the amount
that I wanted to go over and I was
amazed I was like is this a cow shake
really making my blood sugar go down and
but I had higher numbers this morning
but at us because I had I'm learning
that I can't eat too much of a snack I
have to lower the amount that I'm eating
and how much of whatever I eat at night
so I'm gonna change and have the maybe
to shake that night and then maybe have
a little more for my snack and a little
bit of a snack and not too much but I
feel a lot better
I've never had my numbers to be this low
and so I felt strange because I'm so
used to them being so high and you not
don't realize that your body feels
different because they've been high so
long you don't know what it's like to
have normal levels and I look at my eyes
this morning my eyes are clear and
they're usually all red in the corners
and everything I have more energy I mean
I'm getting there I actually did walking
yesterday and I'm having been able to do
walking then when I came here I could
get out the bed so I can actually see
the dare are some differences and then
what I'm eating and I'm learning a lot
for reading your book so I'm learning
from what you say in the book and the
different types of foods and what they
do and how they affect me and they do
affect me differently and I feel great
feeling a whole lot better and I'm
looking forward to and I'm looking
forward to getting better first of all
and then losing weight